ein studio ist bild live chef claus
strunz ja klaus gelten wir bald alle
wieder als ungeimpft ja man hört sich
richtig ran trapsen und es macht mich
wirklich ärgerlich weil es folgt dem
gleichen muster wie praktisch alles in
dieser corona pandemie zeit was unsere
regierung verzapft hat also wir wollen
noch mal ganz kurz einsortieren es hieß
wenn man zweifach geimpft ist hat man
ein jahr lang den impfschutz und ist ein
jahr lang sicher dann kamen die ersten
untersuchungen und die ersten experten
und die ersten stimmen sagte haasis hält
gar nicht ein jahr dann höre ich muss
sagen vor einigen wochen schon man muss
vielleicht von neun monaten ausgehen da
habe ich mir zum ersten mal gedacht
dann bin ich also nach neun monaten
ungeimpft und kann nicht mehr am leben
teilnehmen jetzt sind wir schon beim
stand dass die sechs monate zu lang sind
und man eigentlich nach fünf monaten
sich auffrischen lassen muss das
bedeutet zum beispiel für mich
persönlich übermorgen läuft es ab dann
sind fünf monate um und nach den
neuesten bekundungen muss ich mich dann
eigentlich postern lassen und jetzt
kommt die entscheidende frage das ist
bisher so eine empfehlung
alles in dieser verdammt corona pandemie
zeit begann immer mit einer empfehlung
noch eine empfehlung und mit einem
leugnen dass es so kommt und dann wurde
wieder empfohlen und dann hat es der
erste ministerpräsident gesagt also die
eskalationsstufe war genau wie jetzt und
ich sage voraus dass wir am vorabend
stehen einer neuen verordnung eines
neuen gesetzes dass man nach fünf
monaten als ungeimpft gilt und dann
bricht in diesem land des chaos aus und
die wut und zwar zu recht denn das ist
dann was es ist sozusagen der indirekte
lockdown wenn ich nämlich obwohl ich
zweimal geimpft bin nach fünf monaten
oder nach sechs monaten als ungeimpft
gelte dann bedeutet es ja ich kann an
einem zweig leben das offenbar unser
leben wird in deutschland nicht mehr
teilnehmen kein restaurant kein kino
kein nichts und das ist das wofür ich
wirklich warne deshalb sage ich heute
stoppt diesen booster stopp dieses
booster chaos sagt uns endlich die
wahrheit was ihr vorhabt heute ist ein
wichtiger tag dafür heute ist der tag
der wahrheit der vielleicht wichtigste
tage in dieser ganzen pandemie sagt
heute
wie es mit dem bus anhalten wollte
letzte bemerkung und dann lernt aus
euren erfahrungen der vergangenheit was
mich am meisten aufregt und ich glaube
da bin ich gar nicht ganz allein ist der
staat hat sich positioniert als eine um
erziehungsanstalt also lass dich impfen
du böser ungeimpfter bleibt zu haus für
dein hund nach 22 uhr nicht aus das
schreiben wir alles vorher ziemlich um
der stadt ist aber keine um
erziehungsanstalt der staat ist ein
logistikunternehmen und deshalb stellt
endlich diese booster impfungen für alle
überall an jeder ecke bereit ich will
mich jetzt noch mal in drei tagen läuft
es ab sind fünf monate um bisher
dachdecker 22 dezember übrigens auch
schon schlecht solchen urlaub plant und
gewinnen dann irgendwo in österreich
oder der schweiz da ist dann plötzlich
zweig und ich geld als ungeimpft obwohl
ich doppelt games bin das ist doch alles
völlig verrückt und es gibt eine
personengruppe die klarheit schaffen
kann und die tritt heute zusammen bei
der mpk und die muss es heute tun sonst
ist das nächste für sagen schon wieder
auf den tisch was mich mal was ganz
pragmatisches frage haben ja alle dieser
eher auf dem handy na das heißt nicht
die eines tages mal aufmachen und
plötzlich steht da nicht mehr
vollständiger impfschutz was tatsächlich
passiert ich glaube nicht dass über den
impfschutz geht sondern über deinen das
ist ja quasi dein ticket nun zu deiner
freiheit das ticket zur freiheit aber
das habe ich ja ja ja und es wird dann
aber das kennt und gilt nicht mehr
leider schon über fünf monate her und
dann überlegte das muss das bedeutet für
die gastwirte die darauf gebaut haben
die sich diesen merkwürdigen zweig
regeln unterworfen haben stadt auch auf
tests zu setzen und das ist ja das was
man sich klar machen muss ich sage es
jetzt auch mal in aller deutlichkeit na
klar soll man sich impfen lassen weil es
ein selber sicherer macht und das
solidarisch ist aber wenn ich heute eine
einladung machen würde mit gästen dann
wäre für mich was der wichtigste beweis
dass jemand gesund ist der test von
heute vormittag oder mittag denn wir
wissen jetzt dass auch die doppelt
geimpften des virus in sich tragen
können und andere anstecken können das
heißt warum setzen wir nicht wieder auf
der komplett totale test strategie und
gängeln die leute damit dass ich sie
bezahlen müssen und warum dauert das
alles so lange denn wir wissen es doch
schon seit sommer im sommer habe ich das
schon ran trapsen hören wir haben hier
immer wieder gemahnt und die politik ja
war im wahlkampf wollte die leute nicht
hören und jetzt haben wir den salat und
das ist ein ganz bitterer in der
vorweihnachtszeit